We are here with philanthropist, activist,
oh, and Lady Gaga's mom, Cynthia Germanotta.
(audience applauding)
Okay, so if you're sitting at a table with her,
is there anything that you can think of
that she would say about how she sort of
matriculated that pain of the bullying
and the way that she felt,
into channeling it into something that was more empowering
and useful to her?
Yeah, I think she would say,
we talk a lot at the foundation about the impact
that kindness has on your mental health.
Not only kindness to self,
she talks about kindness on the inside
and kindness on the outside.
And you have to be kind inside to yourself first,
before you can help...it's hard.
It's hard.
Look away.
I look away.
I'm working on it.
Do you have any advice for me?
Baby steps.
Yeah, baby, love yourself.
(audience applause)
I'm trying.
Love yourself.
Look in the mirror.
It's okay to look in the mirror
and tell yourself that you love you.
50% of mental health issues develop by the age of 14,
and that's about when it started happening for my daughter.
But it's not uncommon for it to go undiagnosed for 10 years,
and I missed the warning signs.
I didn't know what they were.
And you know, we talk to our girls and our children,
our boys too, about the birds and the bees, right?
We have that talk.
I call, we have to add the flowers and the trees
about their mental health
and having that conversation with them
in the same breath as the birds and the bees.
And if there was one thing
that I could leave with you or anybody is communication.
And there's times they don't want it,
but communication to a fault, I would say,
and it just keeps that dialogue open.
You know, one person in your life can make a difference.
And if that one, I used to tell my girls,
I may not like everything that you tell me
but I would rather know and be able to help you.
And so just having that one person in your life.
And we found through our work at the foundation
that it's life changing and it's lifesaving
in many instances if you have just one person
that is there for you.
I have looked forward to this conversation
with all of my heart.
I admire, like I said, you and your family.
I admire what you're putting out into the world,
what you're contributing to the world,
how you're taking people in and making them feel safe.
And the Born This Way Foundation
is making a huge difference.
And we're all also in love with your daughter
and listening to her.
She's modeling a lot for us.
I know that's a lot of pressure,
but she steps up to that plate.
So watching her be who she is
is just a complete inspiration in every sense of the word
and I think there's such serious credibility
to what you and your daughter are doing.
So thank you.
Thank you, yeah.
Thank you so much.
Go to our website at TheDrewBarrymoreShow.com
to learn more about The Born This Way Foundation.
(lively music)